le secrétaire d'état la réforme
territoriale en ré vallini l invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir au sommet mais
suri merci d'être là au moment où le
gouvernement fait l'objet de différents
tirs de barrage venant de la gauche et
pas que évidemment du patronat et de la
droite aussi mais c'est vrai de la
réforme que vous êtes chargé de mettre
sur les rails la réforme territoriale
c'est vrai aussi de la politique
économique qui est engagée avec le pacte
de responsabilité avec moi ce soir car
ils paieraient de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire comme
chaque semaine avec dailymotion et bien
sûr perrine tarneaud de public sénat
d'abord andré vallini la garde à vue
sans précédent sous la vème république
un ancien chef de l'état nicolas sarkozy
est donc soupçonné de trafic d'influencé
de violation du secret de l'instruction
c'est de l'acharnement et même un
complot disent certains de ses partisans
que leur répondez vous je dis qu'il faut
respecter la justice
dans une démocratie la justice fait son
travail et les saules à faire son
travail
je suis sans doute
évidemment compréhensif à l'égard des
amis des proches de nicolas sarkozy
c'est une épreuve qu'il traverse
mais c'est la justice la justice
aujourd'hui est indépendante elle
fonctionne de façon totalement
indépendante laissons la travailler je
n'ai aucun commentaire à faire sur cette
affaire en particulier comme sur les
autres vous reer en ferr à la visite et
de la justice aujourd'hui est
indépendante elle ne l'était pas
précédemment sur le précédent
quinquennat
elle ne l'a pas toujours été autant
aujourd'hui elle est vraiment
indépendante
est ce un justiciable comme les autres
alors qu'à l'ump certains voient
aujourd'hui un règlement de compte dans
ce qui se passe des juges disent
certains on se souvient des propos de
l'ancien président de la république sur
les juges d'instruction voire du pouvoir
certains évoquent à l'ump un cabinet
noir
on juge toujours les autres d'après soi
même voilà donc à gauche on est
totalement étranger à ce genre de choses
cabinet loire manipulation de la justice
depuis 2012 françois hollande et je
connais bien françois hollande et
notamment sur ces questions de justice
puisque j'étais secrétaire national du
ps pendant dix ans chargé de la justice
j'ai été son conseiller justice pendant
l'élection présidentielle françois
hollande respecte scrupuleusement
l'indépendance des magistrats
laissons-les faire leur travail est ce
que il est encore possible aujourd'hui
selon vous pour nicolas sarkozy d'
envisager son retour en vue de 2017 est
ce qu'il est temps en capacité de
revenir dans le jeu politique avec ce
climat d'insécurité
judiciaire autour de lui ce sera à lui
de le dire vous savez moi je pars du
principe que quand on est au
gouvernement
dans la majorité on travaille pour le
pays on ne s'occupe pas trop
d'opposition d'ailleurs à s'occupe très
bien d'elle même tout seul
laissons les à leurs problèmes à leurs
divisions chaque famille politique un
jour ou l'autre est divisée d'ailleurs
moi jeunes ironise pas sur l'opposition
jeu je ne bosse pas sur le mp je suis au
gouvernement pour travailler dans
l'intérêt des français de la france avec
cette réforme territoriale alors on va
en parler de cette réforme tout de suite
bien sûr le conseil constitutionnel donc
vous permet aujourd'hui de contourner un
premier obstacle qui a été dressée sur
votre route par une majorité hétéroclite
comme on dit au sénat puisqu'elle va des
communistes à l'ump en passant par les
radicaux de gauche
mais vous êtes au courant déjà bien sûr
la guérilla va se poursuivre oui je
trouvais ça on est prêt évidemment à
tout le débat parlementaire sous toutes
ses formes mais je pense que le temps
est venu maintenant vraiment d'avoir un
vrai débat parlementaire
il y à des sénateurs qui sont favorables
à la réforme il y en a et puis il y en a
qui sont moins favorables à la réforme
et fort une majorité on verra au moment
où ils l'ont montré au moment du vote
oui ils l'ont montré sur des motions de
procédure sur des sur des manoeuvres de
retardement sur le fond de la réforme
on verra ce qu'il sortira du débat
parlementaire mais que le débat commence
enfin
débattons au fond de cette réforme ceux
qui sont hostiles à cette réforme
ceux qui ont des réticences des
résistances des critiques à formuler qui
les formulent enfin dans l'hémicycle que
le débat s'engage devant les français
ils vous disent par avance nous imposer
un débat rapide athée et bâclée on ne
pose aucun débat bâclé
on souhaite simplement que le débat
parlementaire dans les formes prévues
par la constitution puisse enfin
s'engager au sénat puis à l'assemblée
et vous pensez-vous sortir de ce chemin
de croix qui s'ouvre devant monsieur
vallini
non il faut pas exagérer ça attendez là
là voilà il y à une le dépôt d'une
motion référendaire toujours par les
communistes les radicaux de gauche
nouvel obstacle nouvel obstacle que nous
franchirons rapidement dans les 24
heures je pense
j'espère que d'ici la fin de la semaine
je dis si tout va bien nous pourrons
enfin commencer à débattre du projet de
réforme territoriale
d'accord mais si on s'arrête un instant
sur cette motion référendaire est ce
qu'une consultation de la population
c'est une hérésie sur un tel changement
administratif de la france
or quelle question faut-il poser si vous
posez une question faut-il réformer la
france
la réponse sera évidemment oui faut-il
réformer l'organisation territoriale de
la france
la réponse sera oui mais c'est un peu
vague comme question ce serait une
utilisation un peu détournée du
référendum
en revanche si on descend un peu plus
dans le détail de la réforme on arrive à
une impossibilité comment consultés par
référendum les français sur des sujets
aussi techniques voire compliquée que
les départements les régions la clause
de compétence générale
les transferts de compétences d'une
collectivité à une autre c'est très
compliqué donc c'est le genre même de
réforme qui ne se prêtent pas un
référendum sauf un référendum plébiscite
oui ou non vous voulez vous qu'on
réforme des territoires les français
vont répondre oui on n'aura pas beaucoup
d'entre vous c'est la fausse piste par
excellence a avancé aujourd'hui encore
une fois par les communistes
et puis les radicaux de gauche est-ce
que vous êtes prêts à vous vous avez dit
que le débat va reprendre très vite
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à travailler
tout l'été mais bien sûr on est là pour
ça et nous l'été je dire juillet s'il
faut se priver de vacances on se privera
de vacances bien sûr nous voulons que ce
texte soit voté avant la fin de l'année
donc si les manoeuvres de retardement
continuons siégera autant que de besoin
pour que ce texte soit adopté
en tout cas examiné en première lecture
au sénat puis à l'assemblée très bien
vous dit aux parlementaires aux
sénateurs d'abord tenez vous prêts
éventuellement d'une cg tout l'été
juillet-août bien sûr quand l'intérêt
général est en jeu il faut pas regarder
le mois d'août où le mois de juillet où
les vacances au siège au parlement le
gouvernement est là pour répondre aux
parlementaires autant que de besoin
est ce que le sénat joue avec le feu en
tous les cas la majorité hétéroclite que
j'évoquais il ya un instant andré
vallini est ce qu'elle donne une
mauvaise image d'elle-même la majorité
peut-être ici au sénat de circonstance
et est ce que le sénat lui donne une
mauvaise image de lui-même corse ce que
cambadélis premier secrétaire du ps sans
play-offs cambadélis a appelé le
conservatisme du du sénat l'immobilisme
du sénat moi je pense que les sénateurs
devraient faire attention effectivement
à l'image que donne cette majorité
négative si j'ose dire cette majorité
contre est assez hétéroclite qui va de
la droite de l'ump jusqu'au communiste
c'est une première chose les français
ont du mal c'est pour la majorité mais
pour l'institution en elle-même sur le
sénat lui-même moi je pense qu'il faut
qu'il joue pleinement son rôle et le
sénat est utile le sénat c'est de la
chambre des collectivités locales donc
il a beaucoup de choses à dire le sénat
sur cette réforme
chaque sénateur dans son département a
beaucoup de choses à dire parce qu'il
vit les choses avec les maires les
conseillers généraux les conseillers
régionaux
c'est pour ça que je suis impatient de
débattre au fond avec les sénateurs et
je vais même plus loin
le sénat devrait aider le gouvernement à
réussir cette réforme le gouvernement a
besoin du sénat pour rire et pour
réussir une belle et grande réforme
territoriale d'accord avec la flore vous
aider mutuellement on va voir ce un peu
dans le détail et dans un instant mais
je vous propose d'écouter peut-être
quelqu'un qui est l'une de vos bêtes
noires au sénat le président du groupe
rbs c'est à dire les radicaux de gauche
jacques mézard qu'il ya quelques
instants
donc a annoncé le dépôt de cette motion
référendaire et puis il a critiqué ce
découpage qu'avait annoncée par le chef
de l'état découpage des régions pour lui
il a été calqué ce découpage en fait sur
le le poids l'envergure des barons
socialistes on écoute jacques mézard et
vous réagissez que le gouvernement
veuille de grandes régions
on peut l'entendre et c'est quelque
chose contre laquelle nous ne sommes
jamais à prononcer mais qu'ils tiennent
compte de la spécificité des territoires
et qu on ne découpe pas les régions vous
le savez tous en fonction du poids de
tel ou tel grand ténor socialiste
considéré que la bretagne reste seul 1
que nord pas de calais devraient rester
seul etc
on en connaît les raisons tout le monde
c'est pas une méthode pour fabriquer la
france 2
voilà donc jacques mézard interrogé
l'instant par maxime thulliez port
public sénat donc est apparemment ils
parlent d'évidence il dit le découpeur
et fr en fonction du poids des barons
socialistes des régions
que lui répondez moi je lui réponds
premièrement qu'il n'y a pas de
découpage idéal
la carte idéale qui ferait consensus
elle n'existe pas à ce jour beaucoup de
cartons été imaginé dessiné redessiné
depuis le comité balladur
jusqu'à ces derniers jours le débat a
lieu sur la fameuse carte régionale
chacun à sa façon de voir les choses le
gouvernement lui a pris ses
responsabilités il propose une carte et
il la soumet aux débats et cette carte
elle peut évoluer à si oui à attendait
bien sûr revêtir cette suite alors faut
rassurer les élus locaux quelle
proportion
sur quels critères nous l'avons déjà dit
cette carte n'est pas à prendre ou à
laisser si les parlementaires d'abord
les sénateurs puis les députés veulent
bouger telle ou telle région pourquoi
pas nous y sommes ouverts à une
condition c'est qu'on n'augmente pas le
nombre de régions alors 14 est une
limite maximale mais si les sénateurs je
répète propose un autre découpage qu'il
obtient la majorité au sénat puis à
l'assemblée nationale pourquoi pas le
gouvernement est très ouvert et très
respectueux des prérogatives du
parlement mais attention je reviens ce
que je disais au début la carte idéale
n'existe pas moi je me souviens lorsque
rhône alpes a été dessiné il ya une
quarantaine d'années je suis du
département de l'isère donc de ronald je
me souviens des jo qui disait et des
spécialistes aussi et des sénateurs des
députés des parlementaires cette région
rhône alpes ne ressemble à rien elle n'a
aucune cohérence elle commence aux
portes de genève au bord du lac léman
avec la haute-savoie annemasse et elle
descend jusqu'aux portes d'avignon la
drôme provençale aujourd'hui qui remet
en cause les frontières de rhône alpes
elle a acquis sa cohérence c'est une
région dynamique qui existe y compris
maintenant dans l'esprit public
on se sent rhônalpins on se sent d'abord
i0 avoir dauphinois bien
on a des racines provinciales mais
ronald que ça existait au début personne
ne croyait l'avenir de rhône alpes
donc attention à ne pas réagir trop vite
sur cette carte prenons le temps de
comprendre que c'est une carte faite
pour 25,35 en temps on voit des signes
la france du xxième siècle
alors on va écouter ce que disent les
parlementaires on a quelques semaines
pour ça à l'automne reviendra à nouveau
sur la carte
mais d'ici la fin de l'année on devra
avoir établi une nouvelle carte des
régions avec quatorze régions au plus ça
peut être mais ça peut être trouvé une
grève ça peut être très aux doses
après ça fait pas beaucoup un b entre 12
et 14 régions se serait par exemple une
bretagne réunifiée 7 envisagea je ne me
prononce à aucune des régions et surtout
pas la bretagne jeudi que les
parlementaires maintenant de s'emparer
du cas du sujet mais qu'ils débattent
les parlementaires que le débat s'engage
dans l'hémicycle du sénat plutôt que de
voter des motions référendum des motions
de procédure redire
aucune carte de redécoupage est idéal ça
veut dire que celle qui a été présentée
par le chef de l'état est forcément à sa
part d'arbitraire non pas d'arbitraire
le mouroux le mot est sévère non elle à
cette carte elle a le mérite d'exister
certains posent la question de la
picardie d'autres du fait entrer du
poitou charentes elle a été comme ça
réalisé à lattes à la suite de coups de
fil qui ont fait varier le coup de
ciseaux un l'elysée il a dans la journée
gt gt à la fameuse réunion à l'elysée le
soir quand la carte a finalement été
rendue publique avait été unanimement
tardivement mais parce que cette carte
était au débat depuis des semaines dans
les régions dans les départements à
l'assemblée au sénat dans la presse tout
le monde en parlait le président de la
république et le premier ministre ont
beaucoup consulté
moi même j'ai reçu beaucoup de prisons
de région avec manuel valls nous avons
reçu toutes les associations d'élus tout
ça n'est pas sorti comme ça subitement à
21h15 d'un chapeau cette carte est là
elle est le fruit d'une longue
concertation mais il peut y avoir
d'autres cartes alors vous avons demandé
aux parlementaires de devenir
raisonnable aux sénateurs en tous les
cas et de débattre de débattre avec vous
de deir découpage territorial et s'il ya
cette guérilla
cette obstruction qui se poursuivront le
voit c'est le cas aujourd'hui encore est
ce que vous avez envie de contourner
l'obstacle du sénat pour mettre le texte
entre les mains des députés cette fois
d'abord non on ne veut en aucune façon
contournée le sénat au contraire je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure le sénat c'est la
chambre des collectivités locales donc
il est évident que
on commence d'ailleurs parce que la
constitution de prévente commence le
débat au sénat à condition que le débat
commence le jour et à condition à
condition mais si les conditions sont
pas réunies pour 7 ils vont recommencer
ailleurs s'ils sont là bien sûr si les
sénateurs refusent le débat
effectivement motions de procédure après
motions de procédure la règle c'est
qu'ensuite le texte parts à l'assemblée
mais ce serait dommage parce que je le
répète pour faire ce serait dommage mais
c'est une hypothèse je ne veux pas
l'envisager parce que je considère que
l'intelligence collective va l'emporter
au sénat et que les sénateurs de droite
comme de gauche vont aider le
gouvernement à faire une grande réforme
territoriale très bien à suivre donc il
ya une question qui divise une autre ce
sont les économies escomptées par cette
réforme territoriale monsieur vallini
c'est l'un des enjeux de la
simplification de ce qu'on appelle le
mille feuille territorial de cette
clarification des compétences qui c'est
vrai souvent aujourd'hui se chevauchent
alors vous avez avancé un chiffre
au début du débat dit un chiffre qui ne
fait toujours pas l'unanimité avant
d'accueillir karine perrelle de l afp
pour la suite de votre interview
additions et soustractions avec louis
sybille exemples à l'appui la normandie
deux régions côte à côte
l'union semble évidente dans le projet
de réforme territoriale
et pourtant en 2008 une étude a été
menée pour savoir si cela baisserait les
dépenses publiques
le constat est sans appel la fusion
coûterait 15 millions d'euros et serait
amorti en 20 ans vous avez des économies
d'échelle liées à une mutualisation en
fait de da certain nombre de travaux de
fonction mais ces économies d'échelle
elles sont quand même limité et cesse et
c'est à dire que si on prend l'exemple
des lycées vous avez des lycées dans
basse normandie des lycées en haute
normandie vous n'allez pas les regrouper
pour faire des économies d'échelle des
économies bien marginale
la réforme prévoit de diviser les
régions par deux au total le
gouvernement table sur une dizaine de
milliards d'euros d'ici cinq à dix ans
soit 5 % de la masse globale des
collectivités territoriales chez les
parlementaires de gauche ou de droite
personne n'y croit on nous dit je fais
une réforme pour simplifier les
structures territoriales et cela va
apporter des économies
et qu'on ne soit pas capable d'articuler
clairement ces économies de les chiffrer
quand on aura uniformiser les régimes
militaires des sars et sur huit ou dix
départements dans une nouvelle région
on sera obligé de faire par le haut donc
au niveau des salariés des nouvelles
collectivités
ça me gênerait beaucoup plus de dépenses
le budget des collectivités est
d'environ 250 milliards d'euros soit 30
milliards pour les régions 165 pour les
communes et enfin 30 pour les
départements alors où trouver des
économies là où il ya des économies très
importantes à faire c'est au niveau de
tout ce magma les communes les
intercommunalités les opci les syndicats
mixtes
là il faut mettre les mains dans le
cambouis et commencer à dire qui fait
quoi et à empêcher qui est un
recouvrement et des compétences et aussi
ce qui est plus grave et qui coûte très
cher actuellement un recouvrement des
décideurs
les collectivités territoriales ont déjà
des budgets très serrés
l'état leur supprime 28 milliards
d'euros d'ici à 2017 si leur fusion
n'est pas une manne elles devront
trouver ailleurs les ressources
financières avec nos dents car ils
paieraient de l'agencé secrétaires
d'état la réforme territoriale
alors donc vous avez chiffré les
économies à 10 milliards d'euros d'ici
cinq à dix ans vous êtes le seul à
donner un chiffre est ce que ce chiffre
vous les mains puis je n'ai pas chiffré
les économies
j'ai fait part d'une estimation non pas
d'une prévision
à l'euro près j'ai fait part d'une
estimation venant de spécialistes et
notamment la direction générale des
collectivités locales qui ne passe pas
pour rassembler des fantaisistes sont
des gens sérieux à commencer par son
directeur qui m'ont dit que sur une
masse globale de 250 milliards d'euros
250 milliards d'euros à long terme à
moyen et long termes sur une dizaine
d'années à condition d'avoir tout
réformer et notamment la strate communal
le bloc communal comme le disait
monsieur le bras à l'instant communes
syndicats de communes communautés de
communes communautés d'agglomération
syndicat de pays à condition d'avoir
tout réformer sur une dizaine d'années
on peut s'attendre à 5 % d'économies
c'est le chiffre que tous les
spécialistes en organisation
complexe avance lorsqu on rationalise
justement une organisation complexe
or le mille feuille territorial c'est
une organisation complexe à ces
personnes avouent des personnes va
contre sarlat
si en dix ans on n'a pas réussi à
dégager 5 % d'économies sur le
fonctionnement de cet organisme complexe
on n'aura pas réussi notre réforme mais
je précise aussitôt que ce n'est pas
l'objectif de la réforme les économies
dont vous parlez dont je suis sûr qu
elles interviendront à terme ne seront
qu'une conséquence de la réforme la
réforme à la trois objectifs la clarté
la compétitivité et la proximité la
clarté des compétences vous l'avez dit
tout le monde reconnaît que
l'enchevêtrement des compétences entre
toutes ces structures qui se sont
empilées est devenue illisible pour le
citoyen donc ce n'est pas démocratique
quand le citoyen ne comprend plus le
fonctionnement de ses institutions et
lisible aussi pour les élus locaux et
coûteux et lisible et coûte donc il faut
simplifier
est ce que vous savez d'ailleurs et un
chiffre qui est parlant que la france à
elle toute seule
rassemble 40 % des structures
territoriales de toute l'europe à 28 il
ya vaincu paix en europe la france tout
seul contre 40% des structures
territoriales champions dans certains
dom
on est les champions donc il faut
clarifier rendre un simple plus clair
deuxième objectif la compétitivité et
régions grandes puissantes avec le
monopole si j'ose dire du développement
économique de l'innovation de l'aide aux
entreprises des infrastructures des
transports tout ce qui fait
l'attractivité du territoire et enfin
troisième objectif la proximité ce sont
les intercommunalités qui sont
maintenant le meilleur resto pour rendre
les meilleurs services publics aux
citoyens terre donc clarté compétitivité
proximité et puis à la fin comme
conséquence il y aura en plus des
économies c'est un objectif ce sera une
conséquence ce sera une conséquence et
j'en suis sûr parce que j'entendais le
reportage que vous avez diffusé les
fonctions support la maintenance
informatique la maintenance des
bâtiments la gestion conjointe
lycée-collège par la seule région ça va
faire des économies des économies
d'échelle
la suppression des chevauchements de
compétences des doublons ça aussi ça va
faire des économies il ya un rapport le
rapport malvy lambert qui est très
éclairant là dessus sur les économies
fortes que l'on peut
la condition de simplifier
l'organisation territoriale de la
république mais ça prendra bien au delà
de la fin du quinquennat bad as me
paierait mais si pour une fois on
sortait du court termisme de la vision à
courte vue de la prochaine élection de
la fin du quinquennat des prochaines
législatives ou même des prochaines
sénatoriales
si on essaie de voir un peu plus loin la
droite n'arrête pas de nous dire fait
des réformes structurelles on dit
d'accord lesquelles la première de toute
la réforme territoriale
on l'a fait est ce que vous voulez la
voter ah non pas comme ça pas celle ci
et l'ump se défile si j'ose dire passez
moi l'expression
c'est dommage parce que les français en
ont assez de ces réformes qui font
consensus sur le papier entre la droite
et la gauche dont on parle toujours
qu'on annonce sans jamais les réaliser
donc le populisme d'ailleurs le vote en
faveur du front national se nourrit
aussi haut de ses réformes
toujours annoncé toujours attendu mais
sans cesse entravées et retard de vote
françois front national se nourrit
d'abord de l'absence de résultats de la
politique en matière de charge et
d'absence donnait pas les deux les deux
parce que il faut des réformes
structurelles à long terme sortons de
anthony médiator que françois hollande
qui sort et son quinquennat donc je ne
passe pas sur ce terrain là on parle
d'une réforme structurelle qui engage la
france sur 50 au évidemment que françois
hollande pousse cette réforme parce
qu'ils la jugent utile nécessaire pour
le pays
autre réforme structurelle le pacte de
responsabilité
annoncée par françois hollande au début
de l'année est ce que là encore avec des
économies en arrière plan en
arrière-plan vous avez là aussi des deux
grosses difficultés avec la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale on l'a vu avec les
frondeurs qui veulent déposer des
amendements qui menacent de ne pas voter
le budget est-ce que
social oui oui mais alors au prix d'un
intervention plutôt autoritaire du
premier ministre le report des votes sur
le budget de la sécurité sociale
est-ce que vous avez encore une majorité
commencer une situation inédite
nous avons une majorité la preuve la loi
de finances rectificative vient d'être
votée la majorité parlementaire à
l'assemblée au sénat c'est un peu plus
compliqué encore elle est allée vivante
la démocratie parlementaire ça veut dire
qu'il ya un parlement qui exerce ses
prérogatives des parlementaires qui
déposent des amendements et qui
dialoguait gouvernement et ça veut dire
aussi qu'il y ait un gouvernement qui
entend les parlementaires parce que de
deux choses l'une soit les députés
socialistes sont tous très obéissants ne
déposant aucun amendement et alors à ce
moment là on est très très de députés
godillots soit les députés socialistes
ou les autres d'ailleurs mêlant par des
députés socialistes jouent leur rôle
sans franchir la limite infranchissable
qui le refus de voter le budget parce
que ça ce n'est pas envisageable mais
enfin ils jouent leur rôle en déposant
des amendements il dialogue avec le
ministre du budget le ministre des
finances avec le premier ministre et à
la fin on se met d'accord ce qui n'est
pas envisageable du tout évidemment
c'est le refus de voter le budget
rectificatif ou loi de finances initiale
l'exécutif intervient comme la nuit
dernière en disant report des votes sur
le budget de la sécurité sociale
le vote est réservé il aura lieu le vote
il va avoir lieu le débat continue sur
le financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative aussi le débat va
continuer et moi je suis sûr que ça se
terminera comme aujourd'hui par un vote
unanime du groupe socialiste il y à un
acte fondamental dans toute assemblée
démocratique c'est le vote du budget
dont seul conseil municipal un conseil
général conseil régional au parlement le
vote fondateur renouvelé chaque année le
vote fondateur d'une majorité du lien
entre le parlement et l'exécutif c'est
le vote du budget je ne conçois pas une
seconde qu'un député socialiste ne
puissent pas voter le budget initial ou
rectificatif
donc je n'ai aucune inquiétude il ya
destruction parce que là on se met en
dehors du fonctionnement démocratique et
puis au nom de quoi
20% du groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
pourrait s'affranchir de ce que pensent
80% du groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
tous les partis
mais c'est nous qui sommes de gauche et
ne présentant pas le monopole du
socialisme nous sommes autant de gauche
les uns que les autres nous sommes issus
du même parti ce parti fonctionne sur la
règle simple la plus simple et la plus
belle qui soit en démocratie c'est la
règle de la majorité
quand le débat a eu lieu c'est la
majorité qui doit imposer entre
guillemets ses vues à l'ensemble du
groupe du parti du conseil municipal
dans toutes les assemblées de la
république il en va ainsi on ne peut pas
s'affranchir de cette règle ou alors le
groupe parlementaire socialiste perd sa
cohérence
le gouvernement est alors le
gouvernement est affaiblie et c'est la
gauche dans son ensemble à gauche de
gouvernement la gauche responsable qui
est en danger qui se met en danger
donc c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je
pense que les députés socialistes que
vous appelez les frondeurs ont décidé
aujourd'hui de faire un acte de
responsabilité et on veut quelque chose
en son temps
les temps ne votera pas distille est bon
on verra ce qu'ils visent la semaine
prochaine ils vont continuer à jouer
leur rôle parfois un peu dérangeant oui
parfois un peu stressant pour le
gouvernement ils vont parfois un peu
loin dans leurs déclarations dans leurs
déclarations publiques il faut qu'il
fasse attention aussi parce que que le
débat ait lieu en interne à huit clos si
je veux dire entre socialistes c'est
tout à fait normal
de là à faire le débat sur la place
publique devant les médias c'est
toujours plus ennuyeux parce que ça
donne le sentiment aux français que la
majorité en tous cas les socialistes
sont divisés ils ne sont pas tant que ça
chacun essaie de faire valoir son point
de vue et chaque point de vue
respectables mais attention à la prise
que ça donne aux médias et donc à
l'opinion publique sur le thème le ps
est divisé le groupe parlementaire est
divisée non nous sommes tous réunis
derrière gouvernement pour réussir
pour réussir cette entreprise difficile
car entreprises françois hollande de
redresser le pays de redresser les
comptes du pays
et l'appareil industriel de plus à
retrouver la france dans un état
épouvantable
on n'a pas assez dit en 2012 et deux ans
plus tard et bien nous voyons que nous
devons continuer à écoper si j'ose dire
et à faire en sorte que les comptes du
pays s'améliore le déficit la dette
et puis que l'appareil industriel du
pays se réarment aussi parce que sur n'a
pas de signe tangible qui vont dans ce
sens là hélas pour le pays
monsieur la lutte est longue si le
chômage
bien sûr ils sont ils ne sont pas bons
ce n'est pas une raison aux contrats
pour relâcher l'effort françois hollande
a une qualité que je lui connais depuis
longtemps il est opiniâtre il est
opiniâtre il a fixé un cap et il s'y
tient
certes les sondages ne sont pas bons
mais on ne gouverne pas aux sondages si
on commence à gouverner au sondage
on ne fait plus rien il a une mission
que lui ont confié les français
redresser le pays et ils s'y emploient
avec un premier ministre
efficace énergique est perçu comme tel
par les français opiniâtre c'est pas la
qualité qu'on lui reconnaît en première
et bien moi c'est encore moi surtout
d'être hésitant est aujourd'hui le
patronat par exemple c'est d'avoir
annoncé quelque chose de 31 décembre et
aujourd'hui on arrivait dans l'été il
n'y a rien et est-ce qu'il a changé
d'avis depuis 31 décembre la politique
est toujours la même c'est une politique
de compétitivité des entreprises
alors ça prend un peu de temps il ya des
lois a voté il ya des textes à écrire et
des décrets à sortir il ya de l'argent à
mobiliser ce que vous savez monsieur
grossiord que depuis le mois de mai 7
milliards d'euros 7 milliards d'euros
ont été distribués aux entreprises avec
le crédit impôt compétitivité pour
alléger leur charge le par le patronat
ne le dit pas ça 7 milliards d'euros
il y en aura très d'ici la fin de
l'année 20 milliards cette année 20
milliards entre qu'elles ont raid et les
entreprises à être plus compétitives il
ne change pas de cap françois hollande
il est opiniâtre
alors je lis des choses sur lui qui sont
totalement fausses et je connais depuis
20 ans j'étais à ses côtés quand il
était très bas dans les sondages
un et qu'on ne donnait même pas parmi
les présidentiables il n'a jamais changé
de ligne ni de cap il sait où il va il
emmène la france vers son redressement
pour le moment les français ne sont pas
très satisfait de la politique parce
qu'il n'aura pas les résultats tangibles
mais je fais confiance moi à la vision
qu'a le chef de l'état second départ son
premier ministre
le cap c'est le redressement du pays ça
prendra un peu de temps ces premiers
ministres justement il est un pris en
étau entre le patronat qui lui dit là il
ya deux trois jours ça ne va pas assez
vite on n'a pas assez de gages le pack
de responsabilité les
les baisses des aides aux entreprises ça
va passer vite et puis donc ces
frondeurs qui disent on donne trop de
cadeaux aux entreprises comment sortir
de ça d'abord à ce ne sont pas des
cadeaux c'est une aide aux aux
entreprises pour les aider à être
compétitives deuxièmement sur le
patronat moi j'aimerais que le patronat
français que le medef en particulier que
monsieur gattaz pour ne pas citer qui
est dauphinois comme moi qui te voir ont
comme moi je le connais bien j'ai connu
son père je connais son frère qui est
médecin dans la ville où j'habite à
voiron j'aimerais que monsieur gattaz
fasse preuve d'esprit de responsabilité
en cessant de harceler le gouvernement
le gouvernement mène une politique qui
est celle de l'offre comme disent les
économistes
on s'intéresse et c'est nouveau chez les
socialistes on s'intéresse aux
entreprises à leur compétitivité
nous voulons absolument les rendre mieux
armée sur le marché international
c'est ce que demande monsieur gâteux
gattaz le demande on le fait on le fait
parce qu'il a raison de demander à ce
que les charges soient allégées on le
fait et il n'en a jamais assez et ils en
demandent toujours plus
je le répète et 7 milliards d'euros
pourquoi monsieur gâtés ce dont parle
t'il pas l'échec là que viennent de
rassurer les entreprises pour alléger
leurs charges
le crédit impôt compétitivité les
allègements qui vont continuer à être
mises en oeuvre par le gouvernement
tout ça fonctionne tout ça avance
monsieur gattaz voudrait que se passe en
24 heures d'un coup de baguette magique
non la france est un pays développé un
pays avancés un pays complexe
administrés je ne comprends pas ça entre
l' annonce d'une conférence de presse
présidentielle
et puis la réalisation concrète sur le
terrain des entreprises sur le terrain
en fait il ya quelques mois qui s'écoule
mais on y est on est en plein dans la
réalisation des objectifs du président
at il raison de menaces et de vay côté
la conférence sociale
il appelle motors il a totalement tort
comment peut-on boycotter une grande
conférence sociale où justement le
patronat et les syndicats pour se mettre
autour d'une table pour aider le
gouvernement pour aider le gouvernement
à sortir la france de l'ornière de
l'ornière économique dans laquelle elle
est depuis longtemps bien sûr a fortiori
depuis quelques années depuis les années
2007 2012 où tout exploser les déficits
la dette et le manque de compétitivité
des entreprises nous redressons la
france la cfdt l'a compris c'est ce
n'est pas facile pour la cfdt
et puis pour les militants socialistes
aussi pour les sections socialistes et
moi je suis socialiste et je je vais à
des réunions dans ma fédération de
l'isère
ce n'est pas facile à expliquer une
politique de l'offre à des gens de
gauche c'est nouveau c'est ça demande un
effort intellectuel que font les
socialistes que font des syndicalistes
la cia 20% là de récalcitrants vous avez
été sévère pour les ceux qu'on appelle
les frondeurs à ce que le parti
socialiste l'exécutif de ristourne est
un peu vers les centristes par une
nouvelle configuration
si les centristes veulent nous aider à
réformer le pays et notamment à voter la
réforme territoriale pourquoi pas je
sais qu'il ya beaucoup de centristes
ici au sénat comme à l'assemblée
nationale qui sont intéressés par sa
venue au bloc majoritaire dans la
majorité elle se forme au moment des
élections législatives
on ne change pas de majorité au milieu
du quinquennat très bien merci mais je
le répète si les centristes veut nous
aider son est bien d'accord voilà le
message est passé car ils paieraient
merci à j alain perret perrine tarneaud
public sénat arrive maintenant monsieur
vallini pour évoquer le le tournant
bénéfique qu'aurait constitué le
changement de locataire à matignon va
d'abord un changement que vous a permis
de rejoindre ce moment et puis qui
aurait aussi permis de repartir de
l'avant après deux premières années
hésitante c'est claude bartolone qui le
dit camila campus à nous changement de
style la stratégie anti quoique semble
fonctionner après trois mois à matignon
le contraste est déjà visible dans un
cas jean marc ayrault on avait une
personne qui était assez faible
politiquement et aussi en matière
d'autorité et médiatiquement dans
l'autre on a une espèce de voile à deux
pitbulls super vitamine est super
agressif là aujourd'hui quand c'est la
coi qui a une réaction immédiate de
matignon le ministre est recadrée on
comprend la peine de le recevoir on va
l'engueuler on met en scène l'engueulade
dans les médias donc on met en scène
l'autorité en réalité du premier
ministre ça manquait totalement sous
jean marc ayrault ce nouveau souffle
améliore l'image du gouvernement auprès
du grand public et des parlementaires
je dirais en progrès oui mais je veux
bien que ces quelques engins sur 10 par
exemple aujourd'hui je mettrais 7 sur 10
il ya eu aussi de la part de notre
équipe des couacs des moments où nous à
sa change affaiblit sa chance avoue
l'ailier et la confiance et ça change
le programme est incontestable en tout
cas on sent une plus grande cohérence ou
sur une plus grande détermination sont
j'allais presque dire une plus grande
discipline aux sources discipline de
travail
une cohérence même au sein du couple
exécutif le premier ministre ne souhaite
pas se démarquer d'un millimètre du
président de république avec lequel il
est particulièrement loyal et relation
avec me françois hollande sont assez
équilibrés en réalité entre manuel valls
et françois hollande
ça tient beaucoup à manuel valls qui
fait en sorte de ne jamais empiéter sur
le terrain de françois hollande
encore une fois c'est le président de la
république qui fixe le cap
explication devant les caméras manuel
valls ne s'en lasse pas c'est le premier
ministre qui défend les dossiers
toujours en première ligne
la répartition est réfléchie est bien
rodé françois hollande lui reste en
retrait s'exprime en dernier recours
même si l'hyper communication de manuel
valls d'étain quelque peu sur le
président a aidé ces deux sera jonnier
elle essaie d'avoir un peu plus de punch
il essaie d'être un peu plus dans la
communication
on sent qu'il a du chemin à faire encore
mais ça c'est l'effet val c'est à dire
que hollande sont qui va être regardé et
très vite si en réalité il revient par
la charge
l' équilibre valls hollande reste
fragile l'écart de popularité entre les
deux hommes pourrait bien envenimer les
relations
perrine tarneaud nous a rejoint manuel
valls qui arrive peut-être de
ringardiser françois hollande déjà
peut-être sur la comparaison valls héros
le pitbull valls qui a remplacé un jean
marc ayrault finalement terme et sans
auto et sans autorité ce qu'on a pu voir
dans le reportage ces thèmes est ce que
c'est juste moi je n'étais pas de
membres du gouvernement
jean marc ayrault j'étais parlementaire
mais ça joue ça change beaucoup de
choses d'être gouvernement ou de ne pas
y être
donc je n'ai pas vécu de l'intérieur
fonctionnement du gouvernement ce que je
veux dire c'est que jean marc ayrault à
quelqu'un pour qui j'ai la plus grande
estime du respect et de l'affection je
les ai eus pendant 15 ans comme
président du groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée
et je ne fais pas partie de ceux qui le
critiquent il a eu une tâche difficile
dont il s'est bien acquittée pendant
deux ans un important on entend les
critiques sont faciles aujourd'hui on a
l'impression qu'a posteriori c'était une
erreur de casting à matignon non non je
pense que jean marc ayrault avait la
confiance totale de françois hollande en
2012 ils se connaissaient depuis
longtemps il avait l'habitude de
travailler ensemble et jean marc ayrault
a fait du bon travail aujourd'hui manuel
valls fait du très bon travail je suis
membre de son gouvernement en train qui
faisait du bon travail qui était du 13
jean marc ayrault a fait du très bon
travail manuel valls fait à sa façon qui
est différent du très bon travail aussi
parce que ce travail consiste à
redresser la france
alors certes y'a une différence de
personnalités d'âge aussi valls est plus
jeune il est efficace ça se voit il
risque il regarde il est énergique
experts pourquoi vous attachez vous à ce
genre de considérations françois
hollande est président de la république
il est investi
la communication est un vecteur très
important de senna goji de pédagogie
aussi sur la forme à mettre trop
important la communication superficiel
ce qui compte c'est ce qu'on fait c'est
pas se comparer
c'est ce qu'on fait comment on agit et
puis surtout les résultats de son action
françois hollande y la légitimité que
lui ont donné des millions de français
ça c'est irremplaçable il est le seul
dans la république à être titulaire de
cette légitimité maximale c'est du chef
de l'état il a choisi un premier
ministre efficace énergique et pour les
voir fonctionner ensemble
depuis il y trois mois maintenant je
peux vous dire que ça marche bien parce
qu'on sent même une connivence mars il
ya des regards en conseil des ministres
il ya des sourires entendus
on sent que ça marche j'ai participé à
des réunions sur la fameuse carte
régionale sur la réforme territoriale je
vois que ça marche ça marche bien
manuel valls est très respectueux de la
légitimité de françois hollande qui a
fixé le cap et qui continue à fixer le
cap y compris dans le domaine de la
réforme territoriale et valls et bien
s'emploie très bien exécuté justement là
les consignes présidentielles dans le
dos
même de la réforme territoriale comme
dans les autres ça marche bien entre
j'ajoute que valls ça marche très bien
et autres valses et son gouvernement ça
marche très bien aussi parce qu'on a un
chef de gouvernement qui nous réunit
tous les quinze jours à matignon qui
donne le cap lui à son niveau au niveau
gouvernemental
le débat a lieu pendant deux heures
ensuite on déjeune ensemble donc c'est
convivial
il ya un vrai chef là au gouvernement et
moi j'aime avoir quelqu'un à qui je fais
des textos qui me répond immédiatement
au cio va il donne des directives il a
l'autorité nécessaire n'achète de
gouvernement donc on a un président qui
joue son roi un premier qui joue le sien
mais ce n'est pas de la langue de bois
c'est ce que je ressens profondément
comment andré vallini vous expliquer que
malgré tout la confiance ne remonte pas
vis-à-vis du président de la république
parce que le président est là depuis
deux ans et que les français aient
effectivement sont depuis deux ans dans
la tente de résultats manuel valls vient
d'arriver donc c'est trop tôt pour en
mesurer les effets sur la côte de bien
sûr bien sûr il ya un effet nouveauté
dans dans l'image de manuel valls et
tant mieux d'ailleurs il ya aussi le
fait que les français le voient à agir
beaucoup tous les jours ils montent au
front il était à l'assemblée y répond
par le mont terri vient au sénat
régulièrement il est sur le terrain
les français aiment ça un peu plus il
joue son rôle
on me dit pas ça la santé geraghty oui
je sais pas si c'est pas son genre en
plus de se protéger
il est à l'international il préside le
conseil des ministres les grandes
orientations je peux vous garantir que
c'est lui qui les donnent seulement
voilà comme il est là depuis deux ans et
que c'est lui que les français ont élu
c'est à lui qu'il demande des comptes
c'est d'abord à lui qu'ils demandent des
comptes
et les résultats ne sont pas encore la
série ce qui peut garder cette
légitimité électorale que vous avez
rappelé effectivement avec des sondages
qui descendent qui était gringolts selon
les sondages ça monte ça descend sous
les mots de soutien votre action ça
commence à devenir un rendez vous de mi
temps et des sondages calamiteux qu'il a
pu avoir et il a été réélu sont là sur
les voûtes jacques chirac lorsque jospin
a été premier ministre par les sondages
je le répète si on a le nez rivé sur les
yeux rivés sur les sondages et le nez
comme ça dans le guidon sans prendre un
peu de recul de hauteur on ne fait plus
rien on est tétanisée par les sondages
et on attend de son âge comme tous les
jours on n'avance pas il faut regarder
ce qu'on veut faire pour la france à
long terme
mais avant ces matériaux
dit le chef du gouvernement italien qui
prend en juillet aujourd'hui la tête de
la présidence de l'union européenne
c'est un peu la nouvelle coqueluche
européenne est ce que ça doit être un
modèle pour les hommes politiques
français chomo un modèle peut être pas
mais il faut s'inspirer de la façon
qu'il a d'agir vite moi même au niveau
de la réforme territoriale
je vais d'ailleurs aller en italie
manuel valls m'a demandé d'aller voir
comment faire renzi qui lui aussi
réforme beaucoup l'organisation
territoriale de la république s'était
dit là c'est non c'est non on n'y touche
pas le seul à c'est très important dans
la république ahmed ben salah en italie
ça va pas faire un pli c'est aussi
facile qu'on le dit en france c'est
justement pourquoi je veux aller voir
comment ça se passe tout n'est pas
terminé parce que c'est vrai qu'il a une
méthode qui lui permet d'avancer vite ça
ne satisfait pas tout le monde
vous savez en italie les syndicats
notamment les corps intermédiaires
trouve que sa méthode est un peu
expéditive on va les voir comment il s'y
prend françois hollande c'est un
françois hollande s'est engagé à ne pas
se représenter si le chômage ne baisse
pas à ce qu'il est donc aujourd'hui
quasiment disqualifié pour 2017 mais pas
du tout d'abord le chômage va finir par
se stabiliser la conjoncture va finir
par s'améliorer
les mesures structurelles que nous
prenons pour rendre les entreprises plus
compétitives devraient les amener à
réembaucher cette conjoncture favorable
et le chômage a augmenté de 500 mille
personnes depuis que françois hollande a
été élu donc il faudra qu'ils baissent
d'autant pour que françois hollande
puissent se représenter
s'il respecte sa promesse quand les tact
de la croissance s'appuie cette possible
dans l'état actuel de la croissance non
mais la croissance ne va pas rester à ce
niveau là elle devrait augmenter un peu
la croissance le taux de croissance les
économistes le disent le pense devrait
finir par augmenter la conjoncture
devrait finir par s'améliorer les
mesures structurelles devraient finir
par te prends par produire leurs effets
notamment les entreprises devraient
pouvoir réembaucher la condition qu'ils
les carnets de commandes bien sûr et ça
c'est un problème de pouvoir d'achat
c'est une vraie de consommation mais on
n'a pas pesé au trébuchet l'augmentation
ou la baisse du chômage pour déterminer
si oui ou non au françois hollande
il a parlé globalement il a parlé en
général et c'était au détour d'une
conversation
alors vous voulez des noms je veux dire
qu'il n'a pas fait une déclaration
solennelle aux français sur ce thème il
est tendu vers un seul objectif
redresser le pays
les côtes du pays parce que le pays est
dépendant lorsqu'on a une dette aussi
importante
nous ne sommes plus indépendants tant
qu'il faut diminuer la dette réduire les
déficits
tout ça pour rendre l'économie française
plus compétitive et que la france
retrouve le chemin de la croissance
ça va prendre du temps il reste trois
ans encore un deux années sont écoulés
il en reste 3 je suis optimiste de
nature je connais françois hollande sur
sa volonté de redresser le pays et il va
y arriver
en tout cas un débat s'est déjà engagé à
gauche pour une primaire en vue de la
présidentielle 2017 à ce que ce débat
est légitime sonné surréaliste ce débat
il est surréaliste pour le mans au
travail
on travaille on essaie de répondre aux
attentes des français et on essaie de
redresser le pays 2017 c'est loin on
verra bien en 2016 ce qu'il en est moi
je ne me pose pas ce n'est pas ta
question d'une primaire pourrait se
poser non non je n'ai pas dit ça on dit
qu'en 2016 la présidentielle sera en
ligne de mire on verra comment on aborde
la présidentielle en 2017 pour le moment
on travaille au gouvernement n'a pas le
temps de se perdre en conjectures sur
primaire ou pas primaires ce sont des
débats qui n'intéressent que les
journalistes aient encore une
journaliste de l'émission vous dire que
la présidentielle de 2007 n'a pas d'âge
dans la tête de françois hollande
les journalistes parisiens un peu
certains politiques pas tous moi ça ne
m'intéresse pas je peux vous dire que
dans mon département disait il n'ya pas
une personne qui me demandent ce qui va
se passer en 2017 il pèse va faire une
primaire si hollande est candidat
ça n'intéresse personne dans mon
département et je suis sûr que c'est la
même chose dans tous les départements
donc à paris j'essaie de vous expliquer
que moi j'ai pas le temps de
m'intéresser à ça parce que je lui
travaille je veux que de la réforme
territoriale et celle ci je veux qu'elle
soit votée en 2010 est oui quel regard
vous portez sur sur le quinquennat est
ce que c'est pas devenu un peu une
lessiveuse une essoreuse à président je
vais vous faire une confidence je
m'interroge parfois sur le point de
savoir si on a bien fait de passer au
quinquennat de quelques et là ça
accélère par définition de temps
politique les français souhaitait toutes
les démocraties occidentales fonctionne
maintenant sur un rythme quinquennal ou
presque toutes ces quatre ans aux états
unis
cinq ans à peu près partout ailleurs
c'est vrai que le temps un peu plus
longs du septennat à condition que le
septennat soit non renouvelables pouvait
être une solution je l'avais laissé
entendre à l'époque du débat en 2000
quand lionel jospin a décidé d'inverser
le calendrier surtout de faire voter le
quinquennat avec l'accord de jacques
chirac
aujourd'hui avec le recul on peut se
poser la question enfin nous sommes dans
quelques années on pense que les
français ne comprendraient pas qu'on
revient au septennat même non
renouvelable la question mérite d'être
posée calmement à froid on va t'amener
l'émission avec la une de l'express
cette semaine vous allez l'avoir sur cet
écran ce grand titre avec cette photo de
ségolène royal ces titres l'emmerdeuse
est ce que c'est le seul électron libre
du gouvernement valls ségolène royal
il n'y a pas d' électro libre au
gouvernement chaque ministre est tenu à
la cohérence gouvernementale
ségolène royal a beaucoup d'idées elle a
beaucoup de compétences dans les
domaines qui sont les siens tout le
monde le reconnaît elle vient de
présenter une loi sur la transition
énergétique qui fait quasiment
l'unanimité y compris dans les milieux
écologistes
donc c'est quelqu'un de précieux au
gouvernement pour manuel valls dont le
gouvernement dans son ensemble profite
parce que je le répète elle est très
belle et très pertinentes et à une façon
de voir les choses qui n'appartient qu'à
elle
souvent très pragmatique et en même
temps elle voit loin c'est quelqu'un que
j'apprécie beaucoup
qui au conseil des ministres dans les
rayons de gouvernement à matignon se
comporte comme les autres ministres qui
intervient ni plus ni moins que les
autres et toujours pour dire des choses
intelligentes mais peut-être qu'elle
électron libre aussi parce qu'en dehors
du conseil des ministres et de ces
réunions là elle a un accès un peu plus
direct au président républicain ça ça ne
me regarde pas ok et sur christiane
taubira qui est donnée partante après
l'adoption définitive de son projet de
loi autour de la réforme pénale
cette contrainte pénal c'est plein de
probation est-ce que selon vous des
peines utile oui c'est vrai j'ai fait
adopter la même mise
si vous aviez été à sa place oui mais
c'est une réforme utile parce qu'elle va
permettre de mieux réinsérer les
délinquants d'empêcher la récidive ça
fonctionne partout où ça a été
expérimenté ou ses mises en oeuvre
notamment au canada je me suis rendu au
canada d'une dizaine d'années il faut
des moyens budgétaires importants et
christiane taubira les obtenu il faut
créer des postes de conseillers
d'insertion et de probation il faut des
juges d'application des peines mais
lorsque les moyens sont là
c'est une nouvelle forme vraiment utile
c'est toi réforme intelligente même sac
les moyens sont pas tellement là et que
la droite créola il faudra maintenant
veiller aux moyens budgétaires vous avez
raison vous êtes engagé sur la réforme
territoriale voilà la fin du quinquennat
c'est bien cela ah non il ya elle va
être votée l'année prochaine a révélé
l'année prochaine elle est votre part
vous pourriez devenir ministre de la
justice a pas dit ça mais pour le moment
j'ai beaucoup de travail je me consacre
à la réforme territoriale
merci les bleus iront en finale du
mondial pour vous mais moi je suis
prudent chaque chose en son temps
hier soir ça a été difficile un peu
laborieux donc là temps dans l'es4
normal maintenant et contre l'allemagne
ce n'est jamais facile et on a tiré
quelques plans sur la comète a pas
uniquement sportif et politique aussi
avec vous merci en d'aussi à murcie
mérine bonsoir à tous et à très vite